well this could take some time to slow
down but you can see it was Mitchell
and Brooks with the shove by Donovan you
can
see the ensuing
melee and I believe that that gentleman
in the gray who grabbed
Brooks and took him to the ground was uh
Grizzlies personnel there was the the
ball thrown and then the shove by
Mitchell this has kind of been brewing
on all games they were they had words
earlier in the first quarter
and this is history because remember
Mitchell was in the uh was in the west
with Utah so they've seen each other a
lot
Mitchell threw the ball and then came up
and shoved him and then threw him down
but clearly to me Mitchell was the
aggressor just by looking at it
initially
[Applause]